natural language processing is not an
easy task and when it comes to
domain-specific language things get even
trickier standard pre-trained benchmark
models aren't always useful in industry
specific applications so how can we
train a text classification system on
custom data stay tuned to find out
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to look
at how to use Auto ml natural language
to build a custom text classifier using
a data set from Stack Overflow Stack
Overflow is an incredibly useful tool
and it has saved me on many occasions
but sometimes it gets tedious tagging
questions and I wish it would
automatically generate or at least
suggest some tags when posting a
question so today we will try to build a
machine learning model for recommending
tags for Stack Overflow questions about
machine learning to get started we're
gonna need some training data I have
spoken about the bigquery data sets
program before and it comes to the
rescue here again with over 25 gigabytes
of Stack Overflow questions here I think
we've got enough material to work with
using Auto ml natural language is quite
convenient for our use case because I
don't necessarily know what I want to
build initially it would be great to be
able to easily experiment with a couple
of different options so just start out
let's just try building a simple
classification model that just
differentiates between whether a
question is asking about tensorflow
or other something else the sequel query
we're going to use to pre process this
data it's a little bit involved will
combine the title and the text fields
together into one long string of text
strip out all that HTML formatting tag
nonsense we don't need that and we'll
replace those vertical bars in the tags
with commas so we'll limit our questions
to only be those that are tagged
with tensorflow Karis matplotlib pandas
and scikit-learn that way it's just
machine learning topics so at this point
you might be wondering if we shouldn't
just make a tag recommendation system by
writing say an if statement in some
cases you'd be right
but there's definitely still questions
out there which don't mention the word
tensorflow even though they are about
tensorflow
so to even things out and prevent the
model from using the word tensorflow to
basically cheat and find those questions
about tensorflow let's replace all of
the obvious words with let's say the
word avocado for your work model you can
choose a different food you know now
that our Stack Overflow questions are
all about avocados datasets and avocado
classifiers we can use auto ml natural
language to train a model that decides
whether a question is about tensorflow
or something else
training with auto ml natural language
is very straightforward and you just
click train it seems to have yielded
good results for us and we can test with
a question from outside of our training
set here's one about the dotnet
framework and the model seems to
correctly recognize that it is not about
tensorflow
great so now we can look at something
more useful than just tensorflow or not
labeling the questions with up to five
different tags all about those different
machine learning libraries we can use
our data set just as before and replace
the library names with avocado and we'll
need to update the labels so that
instead of just tensorflow and other we
have all five libraries represented and
we can see in auto ml natural language
that the data sets are roughly balanced
and once we wait for the train to
complete we actually have quite some
good results from the training I was
very happy with this auto ml natural
language shows not just the training
scores and but it also shows false
positives and false negatives for each
of those five classes so this helps us
spot potential errors in our data or
errors in the model we can try a couple
of different sample questions and paste
them into the predict tab of
interface and see if those tags and the
scores are reasonable and in our case
they seem to have turned out pretty well
Auto ml natural language allowed us to
quickly and easily test out some ideas
about our data with different ways of
labeling and training that model we
didn't have to deal with tokenization
word representation models or embeddings
all we needed to do was have an
understanding of our data set and a task
we were hoping to achieve and then see
if the system could make a model that
was suitable for our use case this meant
that we could focus on the problem we
were trying to solve tagging Stack
Overflow questions rather than figuring
out how to model text now that we know
it's possible to build this model and
that the data is there we can weigh the
trade-off between building a custom
model ourselves versus just using the
model that we already made from auto ml
natural language thanks for watching
this episode of cloudy AI adventures and
if you enjoyed it click that like button
and be sure to subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
for now check out the expanded blog post
I've linked below in the description for
more details and examples and be sure to
check out Auto ml natural language and
see what interesting models you can
build
[Music]
you
[Music]